first Speaker Shan uh has a very eclec
mind and to illustrate that I'll mention
that he got pH physics from sorry his
bachelor's in physics from C and was his
PhD in Neuroscience from gby and then he
moved around many departments he sampled
a lot and uh he worked on a lot of
different things so and you see that
also
great he's really the field of
thanks njie for the uh introduction and
uh you know thanks for aliser and Simons
for keeping the show running and Shan
for uh setting up this great semester
and of course sji for really taking the
lead on this Workshop uh he's the one to
to thank for it okay so today I'll be
talking about uh representation learning
in uh two different domains and uh you
know many of us believe representation
learning is important for making
progress uh and achieving
state-of-the-art and rather than looking
at this problem in a vacuum uh it might
help to look at some of the specific
challenges that come up in different
domains uh what are the commonalities
differences and how to get uh and how to
really uh Advance stateof the art so two
domains I'll be looking at today are uh
control and
Robotics uh and you know in the last
maybe two years there's been a lot of
impressive advances uh due to a bunch of
deep learning methods in in controls and
you know one question is just what are
the representations being learned what
are the questions here and uh recently
in the last year I've been looking at
questions in music uh we released this
data set called music net which was a
I'll discuss this later but it's a very
large label data set and music is
interesting because uh you know I think
it shares commonalities and differences
to domains where we've studied quite a
lot so at the low level I think there's
some similarities to uh to Vision
because there's a lot of of kind of
signal processing aspects and I think
very quickly there's commonalities to
language when we start thinking about
composition uh and it'll kind of blend
both of these two
ideas okay so let's start with uh
control problems okay
so uh in the last two years there's been
this Benchmark of control tasks in RL
gym uh this is this physics based
simulator that emot todorov came up with
it's a really nice simulator because you
can uh design the control systems test
things out and transfer to rear Robotics
and it's very very effective and these
uh tasks were this swimmer task which is
you have uh this object here and you
want it to move like a snake uh all the
way up to this ant it's just four-legged
Walker and you wanted to run around uh
there's various cost functions that come
up where typically you know think about
is you want these things to move stay
upright and do it fast okay so uh uh
they're all pre-specified in the
simulator and basically you'll have a
control it takes as input some states
and it'll output an action and this
thing will move around or fall over okay
do these transfer well to robots or
something uh the feeling is yeah it they
actually in fact uh sometimes for
planning in robotics they actually uh
use the simul internally to do the
planning so I come back to this
simulator yeah so the simulator is
really great and mo i meano is a real
roboticist and uh there's questions of
robustness which is a very interesting
issue because you might simulate
something very very well in one you know
specific setting and it might not
transfer because the real world there's
perations uh but as of now I think uh
roboticist really do utilize the
simulator and it's actually used by
roboticist as well to to design things
now there's a question of whether or not
these tasks are good and I'll come back
to that uh but it's definitely one uh
which has been studied quite a lot among
uh some deep learning researchers and
roboticists okay so so these are the
tasks we're going to look at uh this
sort of swimmer Hopper Walker and
cheetah uh why I just quickly review uh
sort of RL and some gradient based
methods so so questions about the tasks
at all I mean I think it's pretty
explanatory I'll show you some videos of
these things working later on okay so uh
let's just quickly review reinforcement
learning I think there's a review talk
on this before but uh you know Mar of
okay I'm just going to review RL in the
context of Mark of decision processes
but we have sort of States actions you
take an action a certain State you move
you get some reward based on the state
you're in and you move based on the
underlying dynamics of the world and
your goal is to find some policy which
maximizes some notion of a long-term
future reward under some starting State
distribution okay that's just RL some
cases we know the model some cases we
have a
simulator uh and uh and and that's the
objective function and obviously if the
number of states are small you can solve
problems like this with dynamic
programming if you know the model okay
so that's uh Mar of decision process in
a
nutshell uh one way in which people
attack these problems is through uh
gradient based
methods so these are uh you know you
have some parametric policy uh which
means that every state it specifies the
distribution over actions you're going
to take uh and you can compute the
gradient of the reward function with
respect to your policy parameters and it
has some functional form which you can
drive and the key point of this
functional form is you can obtain
unbiased estimates of the gradient with
mon Carlo samples okay because uh you
can definitely compute the gradients of
your policy with respect to the
parameters because you know your policy
uh and now you just have to wait them
not by your immediate reward like in
supervised learning you kind of have to
wait them based on the rewards you see
along your trajectory but you can just
work out the math and you can take a
derivative and you can get samples uh
and you know the naive implementation of
this which is called reinforce uh this
is like a vanilla gradient descent
algorithm where you update your
parameters based on some unbiased
estimates of the gradients it doesn't
work all that well and there's typically
like variance reduction techniques that
are needed to get this to work uh but
this is kind of uh one default model in
which you attack these problems uh if
you just have a policy you just have a
policy
parameterization okay so questions about
just vanilla policy
gradients uh the the thing that people
tend to do when they're using um these
policy gradient methods is they tend to
use uh basically like a a certain
preconditioner uh
that you know any anytime you have um
some optimization function if you have
some structure in it uh preconditioning
can often help and in these settings uh
somehow because you're parameterizing a
probability distribution it makes sense
to take into account the fact that you
have a mapping from your parameters to a
probability distribution and this
probability distribution takes you to
reward so basically you what's often
done is you precondition with something
like a fissure information metric based
on this distribution uh it's something
that uh you know it's funny because I
did this paper back when I was in a
graduate school and you know it's one of
these papers that from a theoretical
mindset there it's hard to prove it's
any better but back then like I was like
who cares geometrically It looks
interesting I tossed it out there and it
seems to be uh the default thing that's
used uh and you know you can think of
this as just some poor man's Gus Newton
sort of method where you're just trying
to do some preconditioning but it really
does help in practice uh that it you
know most of the Practical variants are
some variant of uh this gradient descent
with this preconditioner so that's sort
of the the review that uh look one way
we're going to tackle these problems is
come up with a parametric Set uh
parametric model and optimize it with
some local search technique uh and in
this particular case we'll we'll look at
the natural policy gradient because
that's what's uh that's actually what's
used in practice okay or a variant of
this
okay so coming back to uh partly sanj's
question so there's sort of two
state-of-the-art approaches on these gym
tasks one is these trajectory
optimization methods uh really due to uh
OT todorov uh which is if you have the
model what you're going to do is in each
state is you're going to roll out um
sort of do mon Carlo rollouts and choose
the best action based on your roll outs
so this is something that when you're
actually acting in the world at test
time you're still going to be doing
these roll
outs okay so this is at test time you
still need the model and you're still
going to do the roll outs so it's a
little more costly it really depends on
the test it can be very costly to
somewhat costly because actually at test
time you doing roll outs another
approach uh which uh we surprising for a
variety of reasons uh is just directly
optimizing the policy and uh this was
due to um shman at all and surge is they
provided uh some results that were
basically model free methods that they
train these things with policy gradients
uh with various neuron Network
architectures and they were Model free
in the sense that even though they were
using the simulator they they didn't
actually need to know the model they
could train it just by acting in the
world because these the monar estimates
so you can just sort of take your policy
act in the world you're going to get
samples uh and and you could pretend
like you just getting these samples as
if you were acting in the world whereas
these roll out methods you actually need
to take sort of multiple samples from
the same state so these you really are
relying on having the model these model
free based methods you can optimize just
by acting in the world so you need to so
so that means you can actually just
simulate trajectories and what's nice is
they give you compact policies where you
don't actually have to do the roll outs
at test time so once you've learned you
have a policy and you can just deploy it
whereas the top ones you need uh to
actually do the roll out so I think what
surprising is you really could get these
model free methods to work and you could
just have a compact policy yep yeah but
the sample complexity of this is very
high and so it only works if you have a
simulator that you can run faster than
real time so so I agree I agree with
that and I think that's one of the uh
the the open questions so but at
deployment time you don't need the
simulator so so so that's what's nice
soas this one you actually need uh the
simulator at test time right so so yeah
I'll come back to the open questions
that I I certainly believe that variance
reduction is one of the critical issues
uh for these uh model free approaches
because the policy gradients have high
variance okay but uh I'd say that's an
open question so the two things that
went into the the SAU here was the
optimization they use this trust region
method it's very closely related to the
Natural policy gradient and uh the
various deep architectures and we got
interested trying to understand what's
the notion of representations uh being
learned okay
so uh those are the two stateof thee
approaches and we were really interested
in uh you know just trying to take this
and move to a harder robotics test that
they that they couldn't address and
basically what Yan's pointing out is the
simulation uh these model free based
approaches really do suffer from
variance methods and if we wanted to get
this to work on very you know harder
humanoid walking cast it was very likely
we'd have to address these so but again
you know it's sort of it's been a while
since I thought about RL and emo as an
expert so we kind of started From
Scratch and we wanted to understand uh
you know what's the simplest things we
need to get these these things to work
out uh so optimization we just stuck
with the natural gradient method because
vanilla gradient method doesn't work so
well most of the variants were just
variants of some kind of precondition
method uh these problems uh the number
the the state Dimension you have is
typically maybe about 10 to 30
Dimensions so they're typically like
Center of mass and relative joint angles
for these
objects um and you know then there's a
question of how should we Pol uh how
should we uh parameterize our policy to
solve these these
problems so uh you know what's the first
thing you might want to try is let's
just try a linear
policy so so here here I'm going to show
you uh you know one of these uh new
network
policies uh and the other one is going
to be a policy that we learned with a
linear policy and by a linear policy I
mean the control action so the action is
going to be the forces uh maybe maybe
there's like two or three actions in for
this controller which is going to be the
forces applied to a joint angle and uh
one of these is a straight up linear
policy so it's linear in these 10
dimensions and the other's a NE Network
policy
uh and we were kind of shocked once I
did a little debugging uh
it seems pretty good okay so question
yep so linear you mean literally linear
not I mean literally linear we've got
like I mean linear in these relative
like the simulator there's sort of
Natural State space uh there's these
joint angles and center of mass and we
have a force and the the policy is
literally linear in these like 10 to 30
parameters okay and it works fine and it
it was a little surprising because even
emo who sort of wrote this simulator was
like wow like linear actually is fine
for this um
and so that's uh it's linear this is
this fully interconnected new
network uh it it definitely
suggests these problems aren't as hard
as people thought at least in terms of
the representation needed uh to solve
them so so uh if you're using the
natural gradient method also with the
yeah for to train well this one was
their method but we trained it ourselves
without it it's it's not an optimization
uh issue that trp like in the paper it's
basically the same there's like minor
differences but it's not an optimization
issue I mean ideally you would like to
somehow decouple the the studies where
you have optimization methods and you
have representation methods but
ultimately they're tied together because
we don't have uh sort of close form
solutions to um four
mdps so the are couple other little but
it's not an issue for the for these
tasks okay so that's uh linear at least
for this Hopper yep use the same state
for the linear and the neural network
yeah yeah so this is this is like
straight so the the neuron Network gets
the same thing and feeds it through
multiple erors and uh uh and
really identical in terms of how they
look uh and to be uh going back to sj's
policy so the linear policy parameters
so sfts are State Vector we're just
learning a matrix that Maps it to the
actions we need to make it uh stochastic
because uh to to take these gradients
you need a stochastic policy so we have
some covariance metrics which is
diagonal uh that's how they train even
the new network uh controllers they have
some uh function approximator and then
they have some diagonal cor variance
matrics to make it stochastic then and
then you just take your policy gradients
and then we also decided to beef things
up with the uh one of these radio basis
function Chronos because this is uh sort
of my straw man stupid thing to try
these are I never actually implement it
with uh the radio basis function konos I
use these sort of random fora features
so Ben and Ali A long time ago argued
that these are good approximators to
rbfs basically just by for theorem this
is a sort of a poor man's way to
approximate a radio basis function so
the way we you know the other thing we
did was we just cook up a whole bunch of
random features based on fora transforms
uh and then optimize them still with a
linear policy we're not optimizing these
weights so this is just to enrich the
space to make it uh a little beefier but
it's still in the what I would argue as
simple that you know my straw man
approaches is just linear and some kind
of well behaved low deegree polinomial
and this is sort of a random way to to
to learn something in that that space
okay so uh but linear is the one that
you know it's just straight up linear in
the given State
variables okay so now let's look at the
performance curves for these um five
tasks so what I'm looking at here so so
this green line is the uh the published
neon Network architecture
results uh and the red line is linear so
this is iteration and this is the
performance and the blue is the RBF uh
so linear works fine on all of these you
see this cheetah linear is a bit worse
than uh the neon Network which is a bit
worse than the
RBF Colonel but still it's let's come
back to the cheetah but still like
you're getting some performance uh but
all of them I'd say are competitive uh
and in terms of train time the training
time is basically straight up
proportional to the number of parameters
in the model so linear we've got about
100 parameters because typically there's
I think between three to five actions in
these tasks so uh so that weight Matrix
is about 100 parameters in these tasks
the RBF there's like 2 200 parameters
some of these deep learning
architectures are 10,000 so it's like I
don't know like 10 to 15 minutes to
train one of the linear things maybe 5
to 10 hours for some of these new
network ones uh the rbfs are somewhere
in between uh you know note that that
we're not saying linia is the best thing
the you know the best thing to do for
much harder tasks but it is you know at
least this set of benchmarks is not
resolving some of the representational
questions that uh we might be interested
in yep is there any difference or issue
at all of stability between all of the
three methods or great question let me
come back to that this is a this is
really uh you
know that's a great question uh
because you know the the hope is um you
know we we do want to get good working
robotic systems and uh stability is
really one of the questions uh we care
about so I'll come back to that and we
want ways to make these tests harder so
we can really study the representation
of questions because I firmly don't
believe you can just be linear in the
state space for really hard tasks but
the fact that you can do that here
suggests that um we aren't going to
address the representation of questions
with these benchmarks Peter um the train
neurals are they Computing policies that
are substantially different
fromes I mean they're they look the same
uh I think they I mean they look the
same and they're getting the same value
function I mean this is the performance
it's hard to like we didn't explicitly
uh look at the we didn't look at the
kale difference but at the end of the
day I think there's kind of one sort of
controller that works uh that works well
uh but you know this let me come back to
the pation one and argue that this the
similar in a sense so the other thing I
I want to
emphasize is that while we cook up these
performance metrics to some extent we
don't really believe that these per
performance numbers are what we're
interested in in these robotic tests
they're they're kind of a surrogate for
getting the system to do what we want uh
but I'd argue that this difference you
know I'd say the hard part is getting
these things off the ground and
subjectively once you have it off the
ground you've basically got it in a
stable State around the right answer and
you can tweak it from there so so to
emphasize that say let's just look at
the difference between um you know the
biggest Gap in performance between
linear and the RBF controller so linear
is down here it looks like it's a bit
worse than this RBF and this neut in in
between so just look at the the
controllers so now guess again one of
them is the RBF controller and one of
them is the linear controller this one
you could probably guess the difference
any guesses oh yes it's the bottom it's
a bit faster but by any uh by any
account if you see this and the linear
is working you know you can beef it up
because you've really got this thing to
work it's not just falling over randomly
um so a question is a little surprising
as we know uh a kernel with random
feature mapping is actually a two layer
your network the hidden layer is
randomly initialized and the the full
connected layer is fine- tuned and the
activation function is cosign if you do
the neuron network with with random
initialization it should be at least as
good as
as good as the kernel method so I'm I'm
surprised why is it's worse in some
cases okay uh it should be as good if
everything was convex uh in the world
and the point is uh the world isn't
convex and we have uh and we have to
deal with real uh training we have to
deal with real training issues so uh so
this isn't an issue that we have tanch
uh versus the sigmoid it's just look you
train this in some way and it's going to
be a function of your training of your
training algorithm and note that for
these tasks like actually just clamping
the first like for the ne we tried this
as well with sigmoids that you could
just clamp the first layer to be random
and it works fine but this isn't too
surprising that linear works well like
once you see linear works well it's kind
of uh obvious that just bolting on a
little extra stuff is going to make it
work well
but okay so uh the main thing I want to
emphasize here is that you know from the
robotic standpoint theer basically
solves the task uh and getting it to
improve from there isn't really that
difficult by just augmenting some
nonlinearities
okay now for the any questions here okay
so now the for the right question which
is uh look uh you know all of these
things work but we do care about
stability uh and do these policies
behave any differently when it comes to
stability uh and you know I think we've
established that for trying to look at
these harder question questions the way
these tasks are set up doesn't cut it so
the first thing we tried is let's just
give this you know these robots a big
thre because we've got a simulator so uh
you know it wouldn't be fun to just uh
smack it and see what happens so this uh
I think this is a linear policy so now
yeah so the Red Arrows we give it a big
kick and then whoa it you know knock it
over tries to get up uh it
fails uh
and this
is uh this is an issue for uh all of
these tasks and all of the policies uh
none of them generalize any better when
we start thring it so for the the snake
uh you can't thak it but we can turn its
direction and somehow it doesn't know
how to move like it knows how to move
forward and you just rotate it it stops
moving uh which is totally bizarre uh
and the Walker yeah we just knock it
over it's cycling and yeah the just
stands down uh and you know this is a
Neo Network this is an RBF these are the
Neo policies so in terms of the
robustness they're all
terrible and uh you would like them to
be able to get up on their own and and
this is partly due to the fact that you
would have to define a get up task yeah
but you might hope that um uh so we
tried to start it uh just for getting up
but if if we uh let it run for a while
it typically just forgets that how to
get up and uh uh but but but this is an
issue that I think people thought these
were hard and for these harder walking
tasks uh you know if the carrot is up
top and you start on the bottom and you
act randomly you're never going to go up
and get the reward signal so so
typically they start them upright so
they're in a regime where the gradients
are non zero and uh but in these tasks
they're simple enough that just some
sort of random initializations should at
at least get them some reward because
they give they give them a little reward
for getting the center of mass up higher
but in the harder task this is an issue
but what sanjie is saying is right that
look if what we care about is this uh is
getting them up we need some reward what
we actually solve this is uh let's just
try to initialize these things in a
diverse State distribution uh and you
know I'm not convinced this is the right
way forward but we might as well try it
out to see if this makes these tasks any
harder we can get more about controllers
and maybe we can uh get some intuition
between uh hard to enrich our policy
space have we tried to smack them on
leave they go don't don't go fast enough
uh that we haven't tried uh that could
be entertaining
um you know I think in these tests we
could actually uh get that to work you
know if it gives them a velocity bump
and they can control it maybe they they
want the little boost
uh but we you know we haven't tried that
okay
so you know so everything really breaks
in the presence of pations uh the
representational advantages don't seem
to to help at all if we don't couple
them with the training how about tiny
perturbations I must be a limit I mean
yeah there's a limit can compare them
with respect to to to this kind of
robustness uh I mean I think in
terms um we can but I I think that the
point I want to make here is that the
tasks are pretty easy and we really care
about harder tasks so right like I don't
really care about the differences
between these policies at this point
right we want to make harder tasks and
uh you know why they B to put ABS well
it's kind of obvious right that these
learn policies are very uh trajectory
Centric they're optimal where they um
you know where they tend to visit it's a
very different issue than in supervised
learning which is like if you're optimal
under the distribution great uh in real
robotics problems being optimal where
you visit isn't great because the the
system will be shaken a bit um so you
know the naive thing is we're just going
to use a diverse uh initial State
distribution uh see if that works see if
there's differences in these
policies uh and you know I think it's an
open problem for how to really deal with
robustness issues more generally uh but
once you uh so once we sort of train
these diverse initial conditions uh then
you know linear doesn't solve you know
then there's a somewhat difference
between linear and the rbfs like the
linear is still somewhat okay but it's
not nearly as good as the RBF and neur
networks but the rbfs um they're hard to
beat uh so I'm not going to give you
show show you the the performance plots
uh but rbfs in the paper are are pretty
much the best here uh but still we can
solve all of them which suggest they're
pretty easy so so these things will show
you
uh a kick we should see at some point in
time uh There He Go so you see some of
them get hit but they come over I think
this one will get a large a large force
and uh uh you know we turn the snake
around and it'll still move forward lo
and behold if we rotate it uh and the
same thing for the hopper so all of them
get solved uh if you just beef up the
the RBF a little and for the most part
the linear isn't all that bad like some
times it won't work but the fact that
Linea is still okay is a I think is
still a little surprising so so to get
them to sort of be more robust um so
you're like kind of starting them at
different yeah I'm just starting them at
different configurations and training
and then just beefing up the rvf is sort
of enough not even beefing up just using
the same 2500 yeah and same linear and
it's
uh yeah so there's no real augmentation
in terms of the the network Ure just we
retraining under these different
distributions and uh and it seems uh
seems fine so you know the take-home is
uh you know we have we're certainly
making a lot of progress in robotics uh
there's a number of issues to address
with regards to robustness
representation uh and what it means to
get to harder tasks but the current set
of uh benchmarks don't really uh resolve
some of these uh resolve some of these
issues uh so you know I think it's just
keep pushing forward start looking at
the harder tasks uh you know I think
there's technical challenges which is uh
how to deal with with uh the variance
issues in these policy gradient methods
because we do want methods that when we
deploy them uh we don't have to do
rollouts so I think that's a very nice
question but we also don't want to pay
the high variance at at test time uh
even with a simulator because uh it is
costly to do these runs and we're doing
them on gpus and
uh
so little longer so uh so that's all I'm
going to say robotics I'll just briefly
uh discuss some of the insights in in
music and discuss this data set are this
questions
here to use policy gr methods you have
to have an estimation of the value
function sorry you have to have an
estimation of the value function for the
policy gradient methods uh we we get mon
estimates of it we we aren't uh we
aren't estimating the value function in
a parametric manner we're Computing uh
estimated values on these trajectories
uh by simulating
them so this is sort of reinforced and
this natural grade just sort of uh gives
us better better modage on the the
gradient
estimates so
uh topic switch uh so I try not to make
it too complicated but it's again in
this question of uh we want to learn
interesting representations uh what are
the insights in different domains uh so
you know in many different domains we
know large label data data sets are
great to have uh music is a domain where
it would be nice to also have a lot of
label data uh it can be hard to get uh
and by label data what we might want to
know is take a particular piece of music
take a random time what are the notes
and instruments at that given time okay
this could be very helpful because if we
had this we could try to take a piece
and try to uh try to train an algorithm
to recognize which notes are being
played when and which instruments
okay and it's difficult to get labels
like this because you can ask in human
to label a piece but then you know I can
give you a piece like um like this Val
string for
that of
Yello I say label dis
piece it's going to be you an expert
could do it if they slow it down and
Mark you know every 50 milliseconds
where things occur but it's uh it's
difficult yep isn't the score itself a
labeled data uh score is a very crude
label data and you could think of the
analog of speech recognition of where
you take uh a you ask people to read
essays and then you have uh labels which
is this is what someone said uh but what
we really want to know is at each time
Point what is being
played okay and and that's uh important
the same thing with speech recognition
you want to know uh you know when I said
the word music like at which particular
time point was the M said and you want
this alignment uh and you know what we
did is we actually found a way to align
the scores to the music so to first
order there's a data set which has done
this alignment so we released this data
set we called it music net inspired by
imag net uh where it's uh over over 30
hours of align music uh and it's real
professionally recorded music uh it's
includes that Revel piece that's
actually aligned on roughly 20
millisecond intervals so it tells you at
each time Point what instruments and
notes are there uh it's again uh it's
sort of limited to the classical domain
so Baro to romantic 10 instruments 10
composers uh you know their short answer
is uh as far as the machine learning
standpoint is concerned uh you could
assume that we've solved the music to
score alignment what are the labels
exactly it's a set it's a set of
instruments is so so the labels would be
every 20 Mills so so so what you're
going to get is you're going to get a
Time series of of pressure which is
sound and a label would be take any
given time point and it'll tell you the
note that's
there or or another way to put it is let
me just show you exactly what the labels
look like in the data set the data set
is going going to be just a large table
it's going to have a start time time and
an end time so this is exactly uh what's
in the data sets the start is 45.2 n
that's seconds the end time is 45.4 n
the instruments of iln the note is G5
the measure is 21 the beat and it's the
note value eight note so it's a the
intervals where the notes appear and
it's marked for all of these instruments
but this one work for jazz where the
score is very approximate uh yeah so so
I think it's a great question of how to
transfer this uh but but in a sense the
two separate issues is how we
constructed the data set and then what
do we do with it so it classical music
was um you know we did this by sort of
what you suggested is we took the the
real recordings we aligned them to the
scores we took the scores generated
synthesized music and found some way to
line it but as far as you're concerned
you have a data set of professional
recordings that that are annotated with
a data set that looks like this okay and
to and to show show you a demo of what
it looks like in pictures is uh this is
the pressure signal this is in a sense
the score these are the durations of the
notes uh when I hit play you'll see the
alignment and it'll tell you when notes
are on and
off play
here getting brighter when the note
starts and
ends
time see you can see hope it's clear
what's going on
[Music]
here okay so uh that's a visual way to
align things yep Jeff have you tried
resynthesizing the music just from the
Align score that has the temporal
nuances of the actual real performance
to see whether or not you're capturing
something that would also be a way of
verifying that the there aren't timing
errors in the alignment so the way we
did the T uh the check the errors is we
just sampled it and explicitly slowed
everything down and independently
checked uh uh check for the alignments
by by slowing things down so sampling is
a good way to check things and then we
had people independently you could
resynthesize it just from the Align
score yeah yeah there's a bunch of ways
we we like there's a bunch of ways to do
that we haven't looked at that method
but we did uh make an attempt to
estimate the error rates in the
procedures by sort of independently
slowing thing down in spot it's much
easier to check uh to check how accurate
things are and uh it's we're thinking
it's like under 4% uh errors um I'll say
you know look at the paper for details
but I think there's a strong case to be
made that the data set is uh you know
it's extremely high quality and it's
readily available so I'm not going to go
into the details of that I just have a
couple minutes uh and I'll wrap things
up I just want to say the data sets out
there go to town uh this is just a list
that um you know lots of minutes lots of
labels very diverse set of instruments
it goes up to even a few octets in there
but lots of quartets uh and that revella
one you know I believe it was robust
because you know John the student on
this uh I was like of course this works
in piano and then he showed me the Revel
that really fast Revel piece and on a 10
millisecond interval I'm like okay let's
just make the data set release it for
the public we got Creative Commons music
so we could release it it's out there
for you to
use um
you know we're really hitting the
supervised learning questions so I think
the first question obviously is if we
just did a data driven way what are the
lowlevel features learned we'd kind of
expect some kind of spectrog grammy
features and lo and behold that's what
we find uh but they're definitely sort
of training issues I think the
interesting questions start coming in is
once we have these lowlevel features uh
then you know my feeling is we need
something like a language model for how
these things are put together and we're
thinking about this now uh I would say
at least um just wrapping up uh where
we're at now is yeah we've got some
lowlevel features but I think the right
thing to do here is uh just use uh
spectrograms and it's arguable Envision
to probably the right thing to do is is
just use some Gabor features which you
can handcraft as well the interesting
thing comes up is what do you do with M
midle
representations uh and you know that's
an exciting question uh you know
representation and learning here I think
should have some in interesting analoges
from what we've done in other settings
so this was these cool demos from vision
of sty transfer where you take one image
take another you can put them together
by what these con Nets have done so this
is I don't know if people have probably
seen this you take two images and
transfer the style it'd be really
interesting to see if we can do analoges
of this and music if we understand uh
you know the structure of Music a little
better there's definitely some uh
musicians that we're collaborating with
to understand these issues there's
various kinds of in questions which
would be uh really interesting to to
play around with in the space of
music to wrap things up um yeah so at
least one direction I've been thinking
about in addition to sort of the
mathematical questions we have in
optimization and representational
learning uh we really want to get
insights from different domains and get
a toolkit that's broadly
applicable uh and you know there
different challenges in different
domains surprisingly uh so for the
controls problems this was joint work
with Kendall uh researcher at udab who's
really got some great insights this was
really arvin's baby uh he did fantastic
work uh on on these uh RL problems uh
emo is just uh extraordinaire in
controls uh he sort of built that
simulator on the music side uh Z is a
recent hire in stats uh John did
phenomenal work in the music domain we
were completely off Bas when we started
the music project we were like let's
just try to use synthesize to do
everything it wasn't working in less
than a year John gave us this data set
and uh we released it uh he's really
done fantastic work and you know more
broadly there's a lot of uh exciting
questions looking at these
representation learning questions in in
par in particular domains and uh you
know lots of open questions uh
thanks time for question or two the next
speaker and come up and set
uh yeah so the low level it's basically
some kind of conet RNN uh for for
learning these uh low-level
features uh for the
midlevel uh this is a good question of
how to tie these things together and we
haven't had had much success with uh RNs
because just the optimization issues
don't seem to work out of the box like
even for these lowl features um they
were just optimization issues I think
it's due to the fact that the
conditioning in these music problems
are it's just m m it's significantly
more poorly conditioned uh because uh
you know you got these low
frequency uh filters up to very very
high frequency filters and I think this
just causes a lot of problems at in the
optimization so I think some you know
core optimization improvements could
help and how to couple this with a Time
series model I think is a is a great
open question and uh we haven't uh just
a na of things we've tried we haven't
been particularly particularly thrilled
with okay
thanks